[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
débat de france 24 entre bamako et paris
rien ne va plus la junte au pouvoir au
mali depuis plus d'un an maintenant mais
finalement exécution la menace qu'elle
agité depuis plusieurs semaines elle
dénonce les accords de défense passé
avec paris et ses partenaires européens
ces derniers fix et notamment le cadre
juridique de la présence dans le pays
des forces françaises barkan et
européennes takouba une décision avant
tout symbolique puisque le processus de
désengagement de ses forces a déjà
commencé depuis quelques semaines paris
en tout cas a réagi tout à l'heure et la
juge cette décision de la jante malienne
injustifiée alors pourquoi cette annonce
intervient maintenant faut-il y voir une
preuve de plus de l'influencé
grandissante de la russie au mali est ce
que ça pourrait se répercuter sur le
retrait en cours de l'opération barkan
quelles conséquences ça peut avoir aussi
sur le terrain dans le cadre de la lutte
anti djihadistes on va en débattre avec
nos invités ce soir le général dominique
delors ancien chef du centre
opérationnel interarmées bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous christophe boisbouvier
à vos côtés directeur adjoint de rfi
radio france internationale chargée de
l'afrique bonsoir merci également d'être
sur ce plateau marie roger biloa
présidente-directrice générale de
african international media group marie
roger biloa bonsoir et puis par skype
avec nous également nyaga les bagayoko
chercheuse et président de l'african
security sector network bonsoir
également merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir répondu présent pour cette
émission alors on va d'abord revenir si
vous le voulez bien en images sur ce qui
s'est passé ces dernières heures sur
toutes les dernières déclarations et
puis on en reparle juste après
c'est une menace qui était brandie
depuis des mois cette fois la junte au
pouvoir au mali la mise à exécution
dans une annonce à la télévision lundi
les militaires ont annoncé rompre les
accords de défense entre le mali et la
france de plus certains trains
république du mali constate avec regret
une détérioration profonde de la
coopération militaire avec la france le
gouvernement de la république du mali
décide de dénoncer un
le traité de coopération en matière de
défense du 16 juillet 2014 les autorités
maliennes ont aussi dénoncé les accords
qui encadraient la présence dans le pays
de la force française barkan et de la
force européenne takouba des accords qui
avaient été noués pour combattre la
présence djihadistes au sahel leur
rupture marque une nouvelle dégradation
des relations entre le mali et ses
anciens alliés en février la france
avait décidé de retirer ses troupes du
pays après des mois de tensions avec la
junte notamment sur ses liens de plus en
plus étroits avec le kremlin l'annoncé
intervient un jour après que le
secrétaire général de l'onu a appelé la
junte malienne ainsi que celle du
burkina faso et de la guinée à rendre le
pouvoir aux civils dès que possible à
cet égard nous avons convenu de
l'importance de poursuivre le dialogue
avec les autorités dé facto des trois
pays afin d'instaurer le retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel dans les délais
les plus brefs les rapports entre paris
et bamako se sont détériorées depuis le
second coup d'état militaire survenu aux
maliens en 2021 pour l'heure paris n'a
pas réagi à ces annonces
alors avant de voir plus précisément les
conséquences que peut avoir cette
décision sur le terrain et ce qu'elle
signifie j'aimerais qu'on comprenne
d'abord pourquoi c'est arrivé maintenant
christophe boisbouvier bois vous faisiez
clairement cela fait suite à deux
semaines de passes d'armes autour de la
sphère du charnier de gossip oui le
pseudo charnier de gossip puisqu'en fait
c'est un drône français qui a filmé des
sommes en train d'enterrer des cadavres
afin que ce charnier soit attribué au
français
et l'armée française a en effet diffusé
les images vidéo prises par ce drone
montrant cette mise en scène macabre et
dénonçant donc la tentative de
manipulation et de fake news contre
l'armée française est évidemment on va
quitter justement le porte parole du
gouvernement malien c'était la semaine
dernière sa réaction
l'un des cas les plus récents a été la
présence illégale d'un drone des forces
françaises le 20 avril 2022 au dessus de
la base de gossip dans le contrôle a été
transférée effectivement au format le 19
avril 2022
le deep run était plaisant à partir de
11h45
pour espionner nos vaillantes format
bouvier en viens d'entendre cette cette
réaction à vous en parliez donc le
maliki accusé la france d' espionnage
oui alors de fait ce drone à survoler
une zone où il se passait des choses
qu'il ne devait pas voir maintenant il
ya une polémique aujourd'hui pour savoir
si la zone sur laquelle était ce drone
au dessus de laquelle ils volaient était
une zone d'exclusion aérienne ou pas
pour les français entre paris et bamako
voyez il ya une polémique de plus on va
dire parce qu'en fait comme vous l'avez
très bien dit dans le sujet précédent ça
dure déjà depuis un an depuis le 2ème
putsch du mois de mai 2021 et marie
roger biloa ça fait longtemps que ça ne
va plus entre paris et bamako ça c'est
encore un nouvel épisode qui vient le
confirmer oui déjà pour l'épisode du
drone ce que je remarque c'est que là
les autorités maliennes actuelle ne
parle pas du fond est-ce que ce que
l'armée française dénonce et même une
tentative de
manipulation est ce que c'est vrai ou
pas moi j'ai cherché partout j'ai pas vu
de réaction sur sa part d'espionnage
c'est quand même ce qui est en train de
se passer quand même aussi grave mais
dont on n'a pas d'information sur sa non
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
d'abord il faut dire que
tout est là le droit de dénoncer des
accords militaires si ça ne convient
plus pourquoi pas
et je sais que ça fait un petit moment
que les maliens se cette junte militaire
putschiste
part de ces accords militaires de
coopération de défense
oui il faut revoir l'une dès lundi
prétexte justement d'urbeis on a envoyé
à la france
nos doléances
notre volonté de modifier c'est ce
traité de coopération mais la france n'a
pas répondu
le vrai problème c est ce que cette gêne
ce qui pousse schiste doublement etc et
un régime de transition a le droit de
que de signer ou de prendre ce genre de
décision que salue bien pas du tout ils
sont pas quelle est leur légitimité
c'est ça le problème de fond peut faire
ce qu'on veut mais ils sont là pour
organiser des élections sécuriser le
pays suffisamment pour qu'on puisse
faire ces élections et remettre un peu
la présence de l'islam à l'intérieur du
territoire on ne voit pas tout ça ce
qu'on voit actuellement c'est que la
classe politique malienne terrorisés
lien un homme politique un leader de
l'opposition qui en train de se cacher
parce que il a eu des propos très
critiques vis-à-vis de cette jeune
militaire et on voulait l'arrêter ce
qu'on voit c'est que
même sur le plan sécuritaire il ya
beaucoup de propagande mais
la menace djihadiste menace terroriste
est en train de s'étendre et ça on en
parlera tout à l'heure tout à fait et
donc
et prennent des mesures qui actuellement
flatte un peu
cette histoire de l'amour propre du
malien vis-à-vis de bison de
souveraineté vitamines la france c'est à
dire la tees des sentiments
qu'on trouve pas mal absolument en
afrique et juste pour leur propre agenda
se maintenir au pouvoir nyaga les
bagayoko cc pour flatter
la population malienne que cette
décision a été prise par la junte
militaire au pouvoir
non je pense qu'il y a effectivement
cette volonté de répondre à la fraction
honte mayenne de l'opinion publique qui
est extrêmement polarisé qui se
réclament du panafricanisme tout en
n'ayant des réactions dite patriotique
nationaliste mais il ya aussi la volonté
de se positionner sur trois terrains
aujourd'hui le terrain de l'affrontement
diplomatique le terrain de
l'affrontement opérationnel est
aujourd'hui très clairement le terrain
de l'affrontement juridique les
arguments avancés
côté malien pour justifier cette
dénonciation des accords interroge dans
la mesure où il est notamment
propres au chai à la france le retrait
unilatéral
des forces alors que j'en ai fait même
s'il n'y a pas eu d'appel officielle du
mali au retrait français il y a eu
clairement une façon de pousser les
autorités françaises à prendre cette
décision
d'autre part il y à ces accusations de
violations de l'espace aérien malien
alors même que l'on a appris qu'il y
avait eu une demande après la taille de
mon gros mois de mars pour que la force
barca viennent apporter à l'appui aérien
et reviennent dans la zone
d'interdiction temporaire de survol qui
lui avait été signifiée général
dominique de leurs risques il faut y
voir la main de la russie derrière cette
décision la russie de plus en plus
présentes dans le pays est ce que ça
pourrait être une forme de répliques
masques et des mercenaires
wagner qui se sont sentis humiliés
justement avec cet épisode de gossip
alors le premier point c'est qu'on veut
divorcer tout est bon donc
c'est à cette affaire de gossip est
effectivement un bon motif deuxième
élément c'est qu'on peut dire que
l'histoire bégaye parce que c'est pas la
première fois que ya un divorce entre la
france et le mali et depuis que le mali
est indépendant et à chaque fois on
retrouve en 61 c'était les soviétiques
et en 2022 ce sont les russes de wagner
alors pour ce qui est des des russes de
wagner on connaît déjà alors leur
méthode depuis depuis quelques années
depuis qu'ils sont allés en république
centrafricaine et depuis qu'ils auront
commencé une guerre informationnelle
très importante avec justement
défectueuse avec des histoires montées
pour essayer de détériorer l'image de la
france donc là
les forces barkan ont été prudentes
astucieuse et l oms après le retrait de
gossip qui se déroulait conformément à
la planification françaises ont mis en
l'air ce drone pour voir ce qui allait
se passer et je dois dire que ils ont
fait un but au sens que ils ont vu des
hommes de wagner et puis accompagné de
quelques soldats maliens heureusement ça
représente à mon avis pas du tout l'état
d'esprit de l'armée malienne en tout cas
de certains soldats maliens qui
accompagne les gens de wagner pour les
trouver en train de fabriquer une
accusation contre la france je comprends
qu'effectivement la junte au pouvoir
soit extrêmement désappointé de voir que
le montage qui s'était en train de faire
pour accuser l'armée française de
massacres tomber complètement tourné
complètement ridicule pour eux alors
évidemment après et rentrent sur des
arguments pseudo juridique d'espacés
aériens ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils sont incapables
de même ils n'ont pas les moyens
justement les français s'appuyait sur
ces accords 2013 pour justifier le
survol de 2 go et si pardon c'est tout à
fait c'est tout à fait logique tout
d'autant plus que l'on a quand même
assurer la sécurité des forces
françaises sans qu'elles sont encore
présentes au mali et je crois que le
chef des armées c'est à dire président
de la république qui tient tout
particulièrement et donc toutes les
mesures prises par des et mes officiel
de marc khanne pour avoir tous les
renseignements voulus sont totalement
justifiées donc là je crois que sur cet
incident on peut alors après on rentre
dans la diplomatie dans les affaires
internationales mais d'un point de vue
strictement militaire est contenue ce
que fait wagner à la fois ce qu'il fait
qu'il mène sur le terrain en puisque on
le soupçonne quand même d'avoir
participé à des massacres très influent
notamment fin mars le massacre de moura
de moura très important plusieurs
centaines de morts on en parle beaucoup
moins à la télévision parce que la
télévision à l'ukraine comme sujet
numéro un on comprend bien mais c'est un
c'est un massacre est quand même de
grande ampleur et puis on voit aussi que
comment on essaie de falsifier
l'histoire avec ce pseudo charnier de
gossip singaye lavrov le chef de la
diplomatie russe a d'ailleurs affirmé
hier officiellement que la société para
militaires russes étaient bien présentes
aux maliens c'est une première mais sur
une base commerciale il a réitéré vous
le voyez que ces mercenaires n'avait
rien à voir avec l'état russe des
mercenaires qui seraient auteurs
d'exactions au mali donc on vient d'en
parler christophe boisbouvier vous
vouliez réagira oui je voulais
poursuivre par rapport à ce que disait
le général c'est vrai qu'on a déjà connu
des fortes tensions franco malienne du
temps de modibo keïta ya 60 ans
mais il ya quand même de fait nouveau
par rapport à cette époque post
coloniale
le premier c'est que vous avez
aujourd'hui un
régime comme le disait marie roger à
l'instant à bamako qui est en mal de
légitimité
et qui donc utilisent leurs sentiments
anti français comme une source de
légitimité il n'a pas par ailleurs
et ça marche dans une partie dans une
partie simplement de l'opinion publique
malienne
donc ça ça c'est une des causes de cette
polémique montante depuis un an et puis
la deuxième chose comme c'est que vous
avez une guerre en ukraine depuis le 24
février et que c'est pas par hasard sans
doute que cet événement cette rupture
consommée entre la france et le mali
arrive aujourd'hui quelques semaines
après le début de la guerre c'est à dire
que vous avez quand même des tensions
très fortes maintenant entre moscou et
tous les pays occidentaux vous
remarquerez d'ailleurs que la rupture de
bamako s'est pas simplement avec la
france et avec tous les pays européens
de l'opération takouba qui sont comme
par hasard aussi des pays de l'union
européenne qui sont aujourd'hui
solidaires contre moscou dont vous avez
cette double tension qu'il ya une
pression mais aussi qui fait je pense
que
ce n'est pas fini l'escaladé c'est pas
fini on est dans l'escaladé verbale on
est dans l'escaladé juridique comme
disait madame à gas co mais on est
peut-être aussi plus tard dans
l'escaladé militaire c'est à dire qu'il
ne faut pas exclure que d'ici la fin
août
d'ici là le retrait définitif des
soldats français de gao et de et de
ménaka il y des il y ait des incidents
entre forces françaises et forces
maliennes il y à des accrochages tout
est possible maintenant donc il faut il
faut être extrêmement vigilant
concrètement la dénonciation de ces
accords ça signifie quoi que désormais
la présence au mali des soldats français
n'est n'est plus légal alors via dans
leur dénonciation il ya les accords
généraux qui ont été signés en 2014 à
koper traité de coopération militaire
pour ça il y a un délai de préavis qui
est de six mois je crois que c'est
pourquoi ce délai de six mois justement
c'est ce qu'ils ont à ce que cet élan le
traité dans le trip dont le texte est
maintenant
c'est en ce qui concerne barkan est à
kouba il souhaite que ce soit avec que
la résiliation de la dénonciation soit
effet immédiat et on peut s'attendre à
ce que bon ça ce n'est pas très clair
dans dans la convention qu'ils appellent
d'ailleurs en sous-face d'études sophos
qui régit les
barkhanes et à coubertin très clair et
mais ce sont les la jeune militaire
souhaite que ce soit un film indien et
je pense que la france va sans doute
contester cela mais le fait est que
toutes ces opérations sont en train de
se retirer la france avait annoncé que
ça a duré quelques mots en 4 simon enfin
quelques mois et je crois que les choses
vont prendre leurs cours parce que c'est
très difficile de faire un tour mais par
contre
c'est tout ça prend effet on peut
craindre un certain nombre de choses par
exemple que la pendant que la france est
en train de se retirer qu'elle
étudié par les d'accrochages possible il
ya des gens avec cesse de clamer l'armée
malienne tout ça moi j'essaie de voir un
peu la partie légale se dire que si la
france n'a plus le droit d'être là il
peut y avoir des problèmes pour le
déplacement des troupes qu'elle a plutôt
des troupes françaises n'ont plus droit
d'entrée au ben ali des problèmes du
placement il peut y avoir aussi
tous ceux qui encadrent un peu là
je dirais les
le traitement des militaires français en
cas de jeu c'est pas un cadre de nos
femmes sous en faire en cas de palomo
que je cherche
dans le cas où ils commettent un délit
ou quelque chose tout ça est
concerné par ça et donc ça va quand même
compliqué la vie à hauteur françaises
qui sont en train déjà de se retirer
donc ça va complexifier le départ des de
barkan les départs sont toujours très
difficiles parce que d'une part yens
manoeuvre logistique et puis il ya toute
la sécurité qui doit accompagner à les
mouvements logistique qui sont très
importants parce blanc quelques années
on avait avec eux et beaucoup de
beaucoup de matériel donc qui doit qui
doit quitter le mali et puis se répartir
sur les autres pays du sahel où on
rentrait en france alors le
il est évident que la couverture du sofa
était permet d'avoir de régler tous les
aspects juridiques une présence
militaire là leur dénonciation à partir
d'aujourd'hui la n'a pas vraiment de
sens
dans la mesure où déjà à la france a
annoncé son retrait que ce retrait est
en cours qu'on leur en a donné les
délais et que si j'ose dire tous ceux se
déroule suivant une mécanique que
pourrait difficilement contester sur le
terrain les autorités maliennes d'abord
parce qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens par
contre effectivement elles peuvent gêner
par des activités sournoise pour
chesnais des mouvements de forces ou des
mouvements des convois logistiques
d'une manière directe ou indirecte car
il est bien bien entendu qu'avec des
amis comme les gens de wagner
les coups fourrés doivent est dans dans
dans leur tête et qui est dénoncé
l'autre jour une jante otages de ces
mercenaires russes en alors otage je
crois pas parce que je pense que je veux
dire le choix de ces colonels de bamako
c'est leur choix alors après que petit à
petit et ils deviennent dépendants dans
ce sens que y arrivent des munitions
aride des véhicules arrivent des
hélicoptères de combat arrive si j'ose
dire à soutien opérationnel réel donc
ils deviennent dépendants maintenant je
très sincèrement
c'est pas si je ne te reste pas très
impressionnés par ce que pourrait être
la france wagner au mali s'ils sont
aussi bons que que leurs confrères
ailleurs je pense que ce n'est pas une
force redoutable par contre elle peut
être dangereuse en fomentant des actions
directes ou indirectes contre les forces
françaises mais pas que contre les
forces françaises parce que les
allemands se pose la question de bâtir
au mali leur détachement qui est très
important dans le cadre de la minus marc
c'est à dire dans la force de l'onu donc
a décidé au moins dix ans dont le
maintien va être décidé au mois de juin
et les pas évident que les allemands
voyant partir tous les français voyant
partir les européens de la force takouba
décide de maintenir leurs propres forces
au sein de la minustah et et sans les
allemands qui apporta un soutien
logistique important la minus maria pia
réel la lame une histoire là se
retrouver en grande difficulté nyaga les
bagayoko qu'est ce qui relie encore
aujourd'hui la france au au mali après
la dénonciation de ces accords par la
jante
il est important de préciser que camilla
et un briquet la dénonciation de
l'accord de coopération entre envies et
des livres sur l'information sur
l'entraînement sur l'échangé de
renseignements et serra n'aura pas
beaucoup de compétences dans la neuvième
n'affluent pas des activités ferries
dans ce quart est d'ores et déjà
suspendu et d'autre part parce que le
délai l'innovation est effectivement
comme l'a indiqué mardi logique joie le
consigner dans le texte en revanche pour
ce qui concerne les deux sofa donc celui
qui a institué la force ferval puis la
forte barca et d'autre part celui en
2020 vient tuer la force d'un coup bas
il n'y a pas de position claire de soins
donc c'est la convention de vienne sur
le droit des traités qui est censé
s'appliquer et c'est en avant quand
celle ci
c'est que le positionne en prêtant à la
france des violations que celle-ci de
contester au nom de cette même
convention de vienne avec elle n'a pas
même avéré mais qui a toujours appliqué
et donc elle peut faire valoir le délai
normal des mondiaux qui est normal en
douze mois pour ce qui concerne les
compétences opérationnelles
il y a en effet dit c'est sont
d'ores-et-déjà 1 est évoqué par mes
collègues mais il ya aussi je pense
qu'il ne faut pas lier la question du
rodez fois au cours du dollar et
articulations du dispositif de marquage
notamment vers le niger et il était
important que je pense que la france
continue à disposer d'un droit de survol
notamment et c'est pour cette opération
et je pense que c'est essentiel sans
risque de l'handicaper en grande partie
enfin pour terminer sur la question du
partenariat malien actuelle avec
l'article du trafic d'accord avec le
général pour considérer que d'un point
de vue opérationnel il est très douteux
que la russie puisse inverser le rapport
au niveau stratégique on voit bien que
d'autres l'acteur jalil de la famille
d'autres 40 ans maintenant y compris
l'effort des affaires dont paris en
vérité là et je ne pense pas ceux des
forces aussi étrangère au continent les
forces russes puissent y parvenir mais
il est vrai que dans le champ de la
guerre opérationnel informationnel
effectivement notamment de par le fait
qu'aucun d'eux
manipulation de l'opinion de fitch a pas
de courants explique la danseuse russe
peut effectivement
un galet bagayoko petits problèmes de
liaison je vais laisser réagir
christophe boisbouvier oui aux propos
est clair pour répondre à votre question
sur qu'est ce qu'il reste
entre les le mali et la france il reste
quand même les deux peuples c'est pas
rien c'est à dire que on se fréquente on
se connaît depuis très très longtemps
depuis des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années on parle la même langue
on a une forte communauté française au
mali on a une très forte communauté
malienne en france et ça c'est pas rien
ça crée des liens humains qui sont plus
forts que tout on a beaucoup de maliens
qui continue d'écouter rfi et de
regarder france 24 par des moyens
détournés ils y arrivent malgré la
coupure décidé il y à un mois et demi on
a ce fort attachement entre nos deux
peuples qui quoi qu'il arrive à mon avis
survivra à cette forte tension on sait
il ya eu trop de déclarations d'amour en
2013 au moment où la force serval a
sauvé la ville de bamako de l'attak des
djihadistes qui fonçait depuis depuis
gao il y a aujourd'hui c'était excessif
bon voilà on a fait ce qu'il fallait
mais voilà il y a aujourd'hui trop de
déclarations d'hostilité j'y crois pas
ça finira par s'arranger nécessairement
ça prendra du temps mais ça finira par
s'arranger marie roger biloa s'éveillera
par s'arranger
certainement parce que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a cinq
militaires dont le but essentiel
prioritaire
j'avais pas dire unique et de se
maintenir au pouvoir et dans cette
histoire je crois que les maliens qui
regarde sa
voix peut voir un moment donné que
ce cette junte qui l'ont dont ils ont
salué l'arrivée parce que ça l arrêté à
un régime qui était déjà conspué
je pense que au mali en guinée ou aussi
les errements de la jeune militaire
commença à faire regretter déjà alpha
condé ça ne fait que quelques mois
et je crois qu'on va se rendre compte
que
là les ces régimes militaires ne sont
pas des solutions actuellement ils font
tout pour
dissimuler les vrais problèmes le vrai
problème c'est que ils ont leur a
demandé un chronogramme pour partir pour
dire combien de temps vous restez ils
ont demandé à faire un mandat complet
cinq ans carrément
tout ça c'est un processus assez longue
de négociation avec la cedeao ou
qu'elles ont fait un mauvais procès à
mont pelé à venir et actuellement
ils ont préféré entraîner le pays dans
des sanctions très très dur aujourd'hui
encore il ya quelques jours on appris
aussi que même la bad de un terreau peas
et les décaissements en faveur des
projets au mali
il préfère entraîner le pays dans tout
ça
aujourd'hui on voit qu'il n'ya pas de
résultats l'ambiance là-bas et des
lecteurs c'est le climat délétère c'est
alioune tine qui est un expert de l'onu
qui le dit on parle de dérive
autocratique
ils sont en train de le l'état n'est
nulle part on disait l'état va occuper
les zones désertées soit d en parler les
djihadistes ya rien de tout cela qui se
passait pour les maliens c'est ça le
problème ils pensaient avoir mieux et
ils ont maintenant une clique sans
légitimité qui peut se maintenir au
pouvoir par tous les moyens y compris en
recrutant des militaires dé wagner pour
les protéger parce qu'on sait bien on
l'a dit aussi vague ne peut pas régler
le problème du terrorisme sont pas là
pour ça c'est juste pour protéger le
pouvoir et actuellement étaient fondées
escalade vis-à-vis de la france alors
que ce n'est pas du tout
leur mission est en train le pays dans
des aventures sans lendemain don c'est
ça le problème aujourd'hui au mali et je
crois qu'on va se rendre compte que le
plus urgent c'est de veiller à ce que
cette jeune tu arrêtes disons
interrompre ce séjour à la tête de
l'état totalement légitime est très
dangereux pour la population et tout ça
justement risque d'avoir un impact sur
la lutte anti jihadistes dans cette
région du sahel une menace qui reste
très importante on va écouter à ce
propos antonio guterres est ce le
secrétaire général de l'onu il
s'exprimait hier
depuis énième et en afrique au niger
lors d'une tournée en afrique de l'ouest
écoutez alors que les attaques
terroristes continuent d'augmenter dans
le sahel et s'étendre vers les états du
golfe de guinée la communauté
internationale doit réaliser que ce
n'est plus seulement une question
régionale africaine mais bien une menace
globale
je continuerai de plaisir comme je le
fais depuis le début de ma fonction pour
la mobilisation de ressources
supplémentaires pour relever ces défis
général dominique de leur tout ça ça ça
complique bien sûr la lutte anti djihad
east dans cette affaire de présence
militaire de militaires au gouvernement
et au pouvoir à bamako est évidemment le
premier victime c'est le peuple malien
mais le deuxième c'est la lutte contre
le lis la miss mme donc ce qu'on peut
s'attendre puisqu'ils vont ouvrir grosso
modo étant incapable de gérer le pays
étant relativement incapables aussi de
lutter contre les djihadistes ils vont
ouvrir un flan important sur tous les
pays de la région et le retrait barkan
va choisir
amplifier ce
ce trou béant dans qu'elle va proliférer
le dialyse walesa sur le burkina faso la
côte d'ivoire le togo dérape et pourquoi
pas même à les franchir la falémé
rentrer au sénégal donc il y a donc à un
vrai risque que malheureusement on
devrait constater dans les mois ou les
années qui viennent alors ceci dit il
faut pas être totalement pessimiste la
communauté internationale notamment les
l'occident mais avec aussi tous ceux qui
veulent avoir des relations commerciales
avec tous les pays africains de la
région vont pousser à un retour à
normale parce que une situation de plus
en plus difficile dans la sous-région
rendra impossible développement des pays
qui doivent avoir accès à tout les
atouts les biens et à toutes les
relations commerciales auxquelles ils
ont raison droit tant que oui la
situation risque de s'aggraver dans les
mois qui viennent
alors maintenant évidemment ça ne
restera jamais aussi grave que ce qui se
passe en europe 1 donc effectivement les
oraux les occidentaux restent focalisés
sur ce qui se passe en ukraine
ce qui se passe au coeur de l'afrique en
tout cas au coeur du sahel valais - les
intéressés mais ça reste ça reste
importante très important et la menace
la menace islamiste avec tout ce que
avec peut-être des résurgences surtout
si j sont si son et des résurgences ça
ne s'est pas arrangée depuis depuis neuf
ans depuis la l'opération française
alors ça c'est pas rangé au sens qu'on
n'a pas jugulé complètement la menace
djihadiste vous avez raison mais
qu'est-ce qu'il en aurait été s'il n'y
avait pas eu barkan
je pourrais ça c'est bien là la question
c'est oui le problème n'est pas réglé
mais si barca n'avait pas été présente
bacofin serval n'avait pas été jouée par
le président précédent et bien bamako
serait tombé et pourquoi pas ensuite
poids gars et pourquoi pas continuer
plus au sud ou au plus à l'ouest donc
ce n'est pas parfait mais si j'ose dire
le malade est aujourd'hui ben
oui on peut dire que servat les
barkhanes ont empêché la défaite mais
n'ont pas permis la victoire
et c'est pour ça qu'il ya aussi ce
désamour aujourd'hui entre une partie de
l'opinion publique malienne et
et la france pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
réussi a vaincu définitivement la menace
djihadiste il ya aussi un autre fait qui
est fondamental c'est l'absence d'état
dans une grande partie du territoire
malien à part quelques villes il n'y a
pas d'état au mali et là je voudrais
saluer la mémoire d'un grand homme qui
s'appelle soumeylou boubèye maïga
que nous que nous tous savons bien connu
que les militaires au pouvoir ont laissé
mourir en prison le 21 mars dernier
c'est une grande perte pour le mali
beaucoup de maliens l'on pleuré le jour
de ses obsèques
c'est un homme qui voulait justement
reconstruire un état pour faire du mali
quelque chose qui ressemble à la
mauritanie au niger c'est à dire des
pays qui arrivent à lutter efficacement
contre le djihadisme c'est pour ça qu'il
ne faut pas désespérer
un mouvement aussi l'autre un aspect qui
me semble très important c'est la cedeao
actuellement on est en temps de lui
faire une réputation on est en train de
de d'en faire le bouc émissaire de la
situation
c'est sûr que la cedeao n'a pas tout
réussi mais enfin c'est quand même
l'organe efficace de la sous-région là
bas même en matière de résolution de
conflits de médiation c'est que ils ont
réglé par là le problème le liberia
celles qui ont fait repartir charles
taylor ou ou bien yahya jammeh en gambie
toujours la cedeao etc etc on peut être
fier quand africaine d'avoir un organe
qui est efficace qui pue qui peut agir
et qui est issu de la communauté de west
kent aussi que même les mêmes l'europe
cherche des organes de ce genre pour
être efficace et y en a pas beaucoup en
afrique la cedeao réunis des lusophones
des anglophones et francophones et
arrive à peser sur le cours des choses
en afrique de l'ouest et donc ce n'est
pas parce que ils ont pas assez critique
est là où
tu roules que ce que qu'ils ne
deviennent qui perdent toute légitimité
et le problème c'est qu'il demande à
l'agent hunt de quitter le pouvoir enfin
de deux demandes
démocratiques et c'est ça le chat qui
leur plaît pas on va tout de suite donné
la parole à niagalén bagayoko qui
voulait réagir et je vous redonne la
parole juste après
oui non ce que je voulais dire c'est que
l'on parle beaucoup l'échec de barca
mais je manque 9 qui s'est produit il
observe m depuis largement comme un
échec collectif à la fois civile et
militaire et dont les leçons qu'on te
voit qu'on tirait
très bien aujourd'hui que les grandes
interventions
civilo-militaires mobilise les autres
humains qui ne permettent pas de faire
face aux pics de conflit extrêmement
complet ce qui se joue sur les terrains
d'intervention
l'action militaire selon un responsable
l'imprimante et culinaires d'ailleurs
plus largement c'est à dire la
mobilisation de la chaîne pénale à
l'invitation des tailles de
renseignements mais ils ne sont pas bien
le général si des pays comme la
mauritanie comme le niger que ce sont
aussi des pays qui sont engagés dont le
père a négocié avec ça et là des
conflits majeurs pour les non pas
tellement la junte lui même le
gouvernement du président ib cas reste
la question centrale de la négociation à
laquelle la france opposée aujourd'hui
quotidien le niger que le burkina faso
par le biais de leur chef de l'état sppe
et lannoy leur volonté de renforcer de
renforcer l'instrument militaire mais
aussi de recourir à la nuit occasion il
ne faut pas oublier que la farine qui du
conflit et
du traitement sécuritaire
c'est un échec collectif comme vient de
le dire ni délégué oui je suis d'accord
je suis d'accord avec un galet quand tu
te dis que
c'est
le demi échec de barkan et de cerval
c'est pas simplement un demi échec
militaire c'est aussi un demi échec de
la part des autorités maliennes qui
n'ont jamais réussi à trouver la bonne
solution politico militaire pour venir à
bout de ces groupes djihadistes
mais oui ça dit depuis que ces conflits
existent depuis qu'on en parle on a
toujours insisté sur le fait qu'on ne
pouvait pas les régler uniquement par
des solutions sous militaire et une fois
qu'on a dit ça on interpelle qui on
interpelle les gouvernements eux mêmes
on a on a
énuméré des problèmes de gouvernance on
a énuméré la corruption et les
inégalités sociales
il ya un certain nombre de choses que
les régimes successifs étaient censés
faire qui n'ont pas fait non plus c'est
pour ça que je dis même si bart kahn n'a
pas été une réussite
il faut pas oublier comment tout ça
convention les a appelés bon il faut pas
oublier tout ça mais il faut aussi être
capable de faire son autocritique qu'est
ce qu'on fait maintenant est ce qu on
fait seulement des escalades verbales
et on prend des décisions comme ça à
l'emporte-pièce
qu'on n'est pas habilité à faire au lieu
au lieu de régler les problèmes
aujourd'hui on a vu
à part les traitements inhumains faire
mourir un ancien premier ministre en
prison qui est malade et cas que toute
l'afrique j'exagère un peu mais tout le
fil demandé sa libération et l'ont pas
fait on a vu que dès qu'ils sont arrivés
au pouvoir très rapidement les problèmes
les hlm problèmes de logement les
militaires se sont servis ils ont
installé leurs familles évidemment comme
ça fait un tollé certaine il ya eu un et
ils ont ils ont reculé un peu mais c'est
pour dire qu' il ya un certain nombre de
choses qu'ils ne font pas que les
maliens qui l'est c'est le saluer leur
arrivée c'était pas pour marca nous il y
avait problème c'est que des mecs il
disait à l'époque il faisait des manifs
pour les instits pour des pour des
trucages électoraux et les problèmes de
corruption donc il y avait un des
demandes très précises à leur égard mais
rien de cela et rien de tout cela n'est
un dernier un dernier mot
un chirurgien il doit être entouré de
médecins d'infirmières
d'aides-soignantes le chirurgien tout
seul arcane part reconnu ne suffit pas
il faut absolument qu'ils soient
entourées et que ce qui est menée sur le
terrain sans suite suivis par les
autorités civiles et administratives de
façon à ce que le terrain dégagé deux de
telle ou telle combattants puissent
revenir dans le sens normal de la
communauté en l'occurrence malienne
n'égale et bagayoko un un dernier mot
aussi avant de se quitter
que la situation aujourd'hui je crois
que les solutions appartient avant tout
aux états sahéliens et que la communauté
internationale
quel toit français qu'elle soit europe
et qu'elles soient américaines qu'elles
soient plus ne pourra pas et les
solutions à la place des états africains
et de leurs opinions publiques sont les
premiers acteurs de cette crise est
celle de se mobiliser et de manière non
ambiguë
on démontre en évolution qu'ils veulent
à rodez et éventuellement en demandant
un truc bien par natal mais la musique
ne peut pas être un rêve aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup merci nyaga les bagayoko
merci beaucoup et général dominique de
leur merci christophe boisbouvier merci
beaucoup marie roger biloa également
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce débat
rester avec nous sur france 24 alain
formation continue
[Musique]